[Musica]
la scelta come modello etico è un un
titolo che mi sta molto a cuore come ben
sanno appunto i miei ex studenti che
stasera decliner secondo un tema che non
è prettamente medico perché di scelte
stiamo parlando questa sera di fronte a
un pubblico che non è fatto soltanto di
personale addetto alla cura ma è fatto
di persone di esseri umani le scelte
scegliere intanto ha una derivazione dal
verbo eligere scegliere ha una
connotazione positiva e come è stato
detto ampiamente in tutti gli interventi
precedenti è qualcosa che ci che ci
capita tutta la vita nel momento in cui
ci svegliamo n momento in cui andiamo a
dormire da quando siamo bambini a quando
quando moriamo cioè la scelta è un atto
che noi compiamo costantemente nell'arco
della vita Di cosa si occupa quindi una
bioeticista rispetto a questo si occupa
di quelli che noi chiamiamo dilemmi
etici cioè di quelle situazioni in cui
la scelta non è facile La scelta è molto
complicata perché ci sono possibilità
varie ci sono opzioni diverse che in
qualche modo hanno tutte una
connotazione positiva e hanno qualche
rischio Quindi di fronte a questo
bisogna avere uno strumento per poter
decidere che cosa è meglio fare perché
non si può agire in modo casuale questo
lo dico ovviamente riferito all'area
medica che è quella più importante per
me Ma riguarda un pochino tutte le
opzioni della vita perché possiamo
lanciare in are Montin a scegliere ma
non sempre funziona in questo modo a
volte va bene a volte no Quindi il punto
del del mio intervento e di ciò che su
cui sto lavorando da anni Oramai è
l'idea che scegliere sia sostanzialmente
una metodologia che implichi un uso
molto forte della nostra capacità di
ragionare Se abbiamo un cervello lo
dobbiamo usare come si fa ad imparare
questa metodologia si impara leggendo
io da anni ho iniziato a occuparmi di
una e a usare come metodo non solo di
insegnamento ma anche di lavoro per me
stessa una tecnica tra virgolette che si
chiama etica narrativa l'etica narrativa
consiste nel leggere e faccio una
citazione iniziale subito da un libro
spetri Ibsen
dove questa donna la protagonista D di
questa tragedia di questo dramma viene
interpellata dal Pastore che le dice Ma
lei signora è molto serena la vedo molto
serena Lei legge tanto come se fosse una
colpa e lei risponde Sì è vero E perché
Perché lei è serena leggendo e lei dice
perché nei libri non trovo delle cose
nuove i libri dicono nient'altro che
quello che noi pensiamo e abbiamo già
dentro soltanto che noi non ce ne
accorgiamo e questo è il punto i libri
l'arte la
musica tutte le arti eh il cinema la
fotografia qualsiasi metteteci dentro
tutto costituiscono la possibilità di
leggere di fronte a noi qualcosa che è
dentro di noi cioè di fa scattare quel
meccanismo di risonanza che ci permette
di capire come affrontare situazioni
complesse leggere È
un'attività fondamentale così come
utilizzare tutti gli strumenti che
l'arte e la capacità artistica delle
persone ci offrono per poter avere una
risonanza cioè sentire dentro di noi o
vedere qualche cosa che ci aiuta a
compiere appunto scelte a volte anche
faticose Come si
sceglie vi faccio qualche esempio e vi
Cito sostanzialmente poi i
libri non soltanto libri per verità ci
sono scelte che non si fanno scelte che
non si fanno perché si sceglie
adeguandosi a quello che è il contesto
fidelio unica opera di Beethoven dove A
un certo punto uno dei protagonisti che
deve uccidere una persona che è stata
condannata morte essendo innocente Tra
l'altro avendo un conflitto di interessi
perché questa persona è il fidanzato di
sua figlia
ehm dice ma io che cosa ci devo fare
questo è il mio dovere mi è stato
ordinato di farlo io non faccio che
adeguarmi Pensate ad Anna arent alla
banalità del male scegliamo perché ci
adeguiamo a quelle che sono le regole le
indicazioni le leggi e le norme di ciò
che ci circonda del mondo che ci
circonda possiamo scegliere che qualcun
altro risolva i nostri problemi c'è una
bellissima poesia di cavafis aspettando
i barbari dove c'è questa strana
situazione di una comunità che sta
aspettando che i barbari invadano la
propria città e sono pronti a lasciarsi
invadere perché è un luogo pieno di
problemi tutto sommato loro V vivere
tranquilli quindi hanno preparato i
festeggiamenti per loro le chiavi della
città e passano tutta la giornata ad
aspettare Questo soltanto che non accade
e quindi verso sera cala questa cappa di
desolazione di tristezza sulle persone
perché perché i barbari non sono sono
arrivati e perché sono desolati perché i
barbari se fossero arrivati sarebbero
stati la soluzione quindi lasciamo che
altri si occupino di ciò di cui ci
dovremmo occupare noi lasciamo che altri
si occupino del nostro destino di ciò
che ci segue ci sono scelte che vengono
fatte secondo un robusto assetto
valoriale personale sono le scelte
eroiche quindi non sono scelte che
possiamo definire come le scelte che
tutti faremo perché non lo sappiamo
fondamentalmente dovremmo trovarci in
queste situazioni ma ci vengono indicate
con chiarezza in particolare da due
tragedie greche al cesti ed Antigone
Antigone più famosa Non a caso sono due
donne tutti e due sono due donne che
decidono di offrire la propria vita
quindi di andare contro quello che è
l'istinto di sopravvivenza primordiale
non voglio morire una per salvare il
marito l'altra per una disobbedienza
ancora più grande Antigone perché vuole
seppellire il corpo del fratello che non
può essere sepolto perché ha tentato di
defenestrare l'attuale re tutti e due
preferiranno morire e tutti e due dicono
negli scambi che hanno l'una con il
marito al cesti e Antigone con il re
dicono ma io debbo piacere Antigone dice
Io debbo piacere di più a chi sta sopra
di te agli dei che non ha te e l'altra
dice È chiaro che se io avessi lasciato
che moriss
tu avrei potuto sposare un nobile che mi
avrebbe aiutato ad allevare i nostri
figli avrei avuto la stessa vita che ho
adesso con te ma non volevo venir meno
non posso venir meno a quello che è il
dovere a quelli che sono al motivo per
cui ho deciso di essere tua moglie
quindi sono due scelte molto precise
fondate sulla percezione che la proprio
valore ciò che costituisce la propria
persona è più importante di tutto ciò
che ci circonda fino al punto da
sacrificare la propria vita è chiaro è
un atto eroico ripeto ci sono scelte che
vengono fatte semplicemente
perché c'è un atto che ci mette di
fronte ad una svolta della nostra vita
c'è un film
ikiru un film di corosa del 1952 che vi
invito a vedere andatelo a cercare sul
web lo trovate riuscite a scaricarlo è
un film bellissimo in cui c'è questo
dipendente statale Lo chiameremmo oggi
un burocrate che per anni che dirige un
ufficio che sbria pratiche per la
Municipalità
e costantemente viene invitato da una
serie di di cittadini a fare cose che
lui in realtà mette da parte in
particolare c'è un gruppo di donne e di
famiglie che si presentano da lui
pressoché settimanalmente portando un
plico in cui gli chiedono di far avviare
la procedura per poter far diventare
parco cittadino un prato che è
abbandonato In modo tale che i bambini
possono giocare lì che le persone si
possano ritrovare E lui continua a dire
sì sì va bene va bene e mette questo
prico in cima ad una lista che diventa
sempre più grande è un uomo sommerso dai
prichi è un uomo sommerso da pratiche
che non vengono mai sbrigate e tutti i
suoi dipendenti che lavorano nello
stesso ufficio lavorano nello stesso
modo perché chiaramente la testimonianza
personale è molto importante In questi
casi Quindi questa pratica continua a
essere rimandata fino a quando a
quest'uomo non viene diagnosticato un
tumore che ha gli dà 6 mesi di vita E
allora decide di fare qualcosa che ha un
senso per la propria vita cioè decide di
far costruire il parco e inizia lui la
battaglia contro la burocrazia di cui è
stato peraltro un Fedele servitore
riuscirà a fare questo il parco verrà
verrà inaugurato dopo che lui sarà morto
tutti i suoi dipendenti diranno
porteremo avanti quello che lui ci ha
insegnato perché abbiamo capito che
questo è il dovere compere ogni giorno
il proprio dovere in modo tale da poter
essere utile comunità e poi in una scena
tristissima alla fine del film si vedono
in realtà inizialmente pochi Pichi e poi
pian piano queste pile che continuano ad
accumularsi Perché Perché scegliere
quotidianamente di fare il proprio
dovere non è facile è la scelta più
complicata che possa capitare nella
nostra vita forse la scelta più
complessa è quello di doverci ricordare
tutti i giorni che abbiamo un compito da
svolgere nella vita e questo è il
modello etico Questa è l' cità della
vita
e come si svolge questa questa
responsabilità vi Cito per ultimo un
libro che è un libro molto bello e molto
duro da leggere è un libro complesso io
ho impiegato molto tempo molto più del
solito per andare fino in fondo si
intitola peog ed è la storia vera di due
padri un padre palestinese e un padre
israeliano che perdono i propri figli
piccoli uno in un attentato e l'altro
perché La figlia viene uccisa a un posto
di blocco per errore dei soldati i due
padri vivono separatamente il dolore
Libo è molto grande un libro voluminoso
e racconta le storie in parallelo
inframezzato le con altre con altre
storie con altre informazioni i due Pari
a un certo punto decidono di conoscersi
ma non perché si perdonano perché si
vogliono bene il loro rapporto rimane
duramente lo stesso cioè sono separati
vivono un dolore profondo quello
inimmaginabile di aver perso un figlio
piccolo di non poterlo R avere indietro
rivedono questa cosa nella loro vita
costantemente però decidono di fare una
scelta precisa quella di incontrarsi e
di iniziare a far incontrare persone dei
due gruppi persone che hanno avuto le
stesse perdite e costituiranno è una
storia vera il gruppo delle famiglie
israeliane e palestinesi che hanno avuto
perdite questi territori che in tutti
questi anni ha tentato abbastanza
vanamente se pensiamo a quello che sta
accadendo che accade tutto orora di far
capire al mondo intero che un'altra
strada è possibile è vana questa cosa
non lo
so Faccio un'ultima citazione ed è la
fatidica frase della narcisistica eroina
di via colvento Domani è un altro giorno
ecco domani non è un altro
giorno Domani è esattamente un giorno
come oggi Questo è il punto il punto
della nostra vita il punto della valore
delle scelte della scelta etica della
scelta come modello etico e che domani
non è mai un altro giorno è oggi già un
altro giorno ed è un altro giorno che
passa è un altro giorno in cui viene
costruito un modello sociale viene
costruita una realtà relazionale viene
costruita una rete di persone secondo
ciò che noi decidiamo di metterci dentro
Allora io voglio legare queste due
parole insieme scelta e responsabilità
perché senza una responsabilità che ci
si prende sulle spalle che è quella che
sono sicura Mol moltissimi di voi hanno
già non si può cambiare il mondo io
credo ancora anche se sono anziana e
fragile che si possa cambiare il mondo
si può cambiare il mondo magari nel
centimetro quadrato che ci appartiene
nel metro quadrato che ci appartiene
nella nostra famiglia con i nostri
vicini con le persone che incontriamo
con le persone a cui parliamo questi
piccoli semi di cambiamento messi
insieme sono quelli che possono portare
alla soluzione dei problemi se ciascuno
di noi si chiude nel proprio piccolo
recino e non fa questa fatica Beh allora
faremo altre scelte ma non Sicuramente
quella di cui sto parlando
Grazie